[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Welcome, everyone.
We are here at the Dev Zone at
the Pizza Authenticator app.
Terry, tell me.
What am I looking at here?
I was promised pie.
All I see is pizza.
What's going on?
TERRY RYAN: It is a
form of pie, right?
So we have an app here that
will authenticate pizza
to a certain region
of the country, right?
We have New York pizza.
We have California
pizza, Chicago pizza.
This app will
judge how authentic
it is for what style
it's supposed to be.
RETO MEIER: OK, interesting.
So actually, why don't
you show us how it works?
TERRY RYAN: So we
have our pizza here.
And we have our tablet here.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
TERRY RYAN: Make sure
it's in focus, and bam.
And now, Pizza Authenticator
is judging whether or not
this pizza is authentic.
So it's chewing on it.
And we see that it is
pretty confident that this
is New York style pizza.
RETO MEIER: Ah, so definitely
pizza, probably from New York.
TERRY RYAN: OK, yeah.
RETO MEIER: OK, let's
check out the [INAUDIBLE]..
It's a good looking pie.
TERRY RYAN: This
is more Midwest.
So let's see.
Make sure it's in focus.
We'll do it again.
She's taking a bite out of that.
Chicago style pizza.
RETO MEIER: Chicago
style, all right.
TERRY RYAN: So that's
good, all right?
Now, we'll finish up.
RETO MEIER: Yeah,
let's do the last one.
I'm curious to what style
of pizza this thinks it is.
TERRY RYAN: I think it knows.
I think it knows what it is.
RETO MEIER: I can't think
of any pie that deserves
to have zucchini on it.
TERRY RYAN: Yep.
Well, here in the
wonderful Golden State,
we make abominations.
RETO MEIER: Yes!
TERRY RYAN:
California, yeah, so it
knew it was California pizza.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
Well, I mean, I'm a huge
supporter of anything that
involves this amount of pizza.
But tell me.
What is the point of this?
Why is this in the Dev Zone?
Why have we got this here?
TERRY RYAN: So this uses
under the covers ML, right?
Machine Learning.
And ML is really
daunting, right?
A lot of people
come to it, and they
think they need to be a
data scientist to do it.
And your rank and file developer
sometimes can't approach it.
Well, we took kind of an
incredibly trivial use of ML
and trained it to
determine whether or not
pizza was authentic.
And all of this, we did.
We grabbed the data.
We classified all the images.
It was all done by me, who is an
app dev, not a data scientist.
So it really shows
that anyone can do ML.
If I can do it,
anyone can do it.
RETO MEIER: So you could take
the same sort of technology
and same approach
here and really
apply it to much more
meaningful projects.
TERRY RYAN: Right.
If you wanted to take
satellite pictures of forests
and see how they
change over time,
and see if you
can identify trees
from the forest for
the trees, right?
You could do that with this.
And that's a much more
serious application of this.
But it's the same principle,
pizza on the forests.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
No, and it's a fun way
to approach Machine
Learning, that sort of stuff.
Fantastic.
All right, now I believe the
real pie is over with Mark.
So we're going to dig
into some of this.
So you pick your
favorite style of pizza.
I'm going to go for the
authenticated New York style.
TERRY RYAN: Oh, I'm
going for New York style.
RETO MEIER: Yeah,
it's hard not to.
So we'll dig into
this, and we're
going to cross over to
you for dessert, Mark.
[MUSIC PLAYING]